[Music]
being able to work on group projects
being able to practice role plays with
my classmates being able to provide and
receive direct feedback all these
require me to work with other people all
these require me to get outside my
comfort zone and learn and stretch and
grow being a student in my classrooms at
the GSB is not a spectator sport the
notion is that depending on the kind of
class we have the instructor and the
goals that they pick the pedagogy that
works best for them professor Krause
Bagwell who is a serious entrepreneur
planted 515 companies in his life
role-playing with him how to fire and
hire people being respectful but still
direct one of the most amazing
experience I had if you're learning
something which is more hardcore you
really need a lecture based approach to
kind of soak in the information I teach
a class in not core which we call
foundations on management accounting
given the nature of the material much of
what I do is lecture and then you have
all these projects where you apply this
information very very transformational
idea that came across in the lecture
that I really value feedback is one of
the core components of the Stanford GSB
experience and you're hit with it really
from day one when this situation
occurred here's how you reacted and
here's how that came off and then you
receive feedback on how the feedback you
gave landed what that allowed me to do
was go back and fix those specific
behaviors so as you think about becoming
a manager someday that's really
important to know how your feedback
comes across from the global side trip I
think the one thing I'll never forget is
probably meeting the sitting president
of Rwanda Paul Kagame the man is
credited for ending the genocide the
interplay between the two of them the
back and forth and sometimes hearing the
different perspectives was hugely
helpful in informing how I think about
business what I want to do who I want to
be and I want to react the one thing the
GSB stresses is that we don't want to be
vetted to any one particular method by
far my best experience was a simulation
of the UN with Professor Condoleezza
Rice as part of her global class what
was about the European crisis we
actually represented Russia I am being
from Germany had to play Greece against
Germany 48 hours later represented to
the former secretary of the state was
just it was amazing if you're gonna
learn how to exercise judgment in the
context of complex situation to me cases
is the best way to do it what might you
do to
we use the case as a platform to
roleplay and and just discuss management
issues and that is so helpful because
they bring the context the situation the
milieu that the case was actually
involved in and that's something that's
missing in just case hardpack and though
we might have studied the case before
with the best solution in mind once we
got there and saw the facts on the
ground the reality was much when I was
accepted at Stanford then one of the
first things I did was figure out how I
could get into extreme affordability so
we come in and we actually take all
these different ideas and when one idea
comes in that's very eccentric or wild
and loud
it actually Spurs an idea that's a
little more acceptable and meaningful
the rest of these are really nice
solutions to problems kind of like and
then pretty soon we find ourselves going
down this path together even though
we're from various different backgrounds
to solve this common need I think it's
really opened my eyes to some of the
interesting insights that can come out
of you know students from the law school
students from the medical school it's
been fantastic the students are always
getting cutting-edge knowledge there are
always classes being taught here that
would never be taught anywhere else
because no one else has even thinking
about the application of what we're
doing to business I wish I could take
all the knowledge I've learned in the
last year and a half have that with me
and go back and do this experience all
over again
there is no question it's more engaging
you